okay now let's take a second to reflect  on these lyrics I roll up I'm going to  be booted stupid and shoot it stupid  brought a knife I brought a Ruger stupid  I really do this if I tote it then you  know I shoot it and I'ma prove it back  back don't be moving stupid or imma use  it yeah this is the kind of moment in a  Takashi song where I know that he gets  me you know he understands where I'm  coming from and I feel a little bit less  alone in the universe because so often I  walk through life feeling frankly booted  and often my wife will say to me honey  you're not booted are you and then I say  yeah I am booted I am and she'll say  we've talked about this and I'll say  okay well if you do if you don't want me  to be booted then get this sucker up out  of my face so just a normal marital spat  that couples have while walking through  Bed Bath and Beyond on a Tuesday